There is a reason to pay much attention
of the individual cells.
Cells are the main building block of life
and are themselves remarkable.
As we have seen in other videos,
inside the cells a whole universe is gathered.
They are much more complex,
than many of us imagine before we begin to study them.
But how we move from cells to tissues.
If you look
your skin, this is the fabric of your skin,
or the tendons or the heart,
different organs have different tissues.
How we move from different tissues
to
a whole multicellular organism.
All tissues and organs
they build a whole organism.
But how cells are collected and coordinated,
how they are stacked in different structures so they build me or you.
Part of the answer
includes the extracellular matrix,
extracellular
matrix.
We said it inside the cells
there is not just a handful of organelles that swim around,
besides them there is a cytoskeleton that gives structure
inside the cage.
Thanks to it, the cage can move, divide,
to transport different things.
Assuming this circle
here is a cell,
what is colored in yellow,
is the cytoskeleton inside the cell.
But there is an analogous structure and outside,
it assists the coordination of cells between them,
this structure
is the extracellular matrix.
It is surrounded by different species
fibers, proteins and glycoproteins,
the most famous of which is
collagen.
I'll paint the collagen in yellow here.
This is a collagen thread here.
Collagen is a very common protein in mammals.
The threads in yellow
are collagen,
I have seen that collagen is around
25-35%, on average 30%, of proteins
in mammals.
30% of the proteins
Roughly speaking, about 30% of the proteins in your body are collagen.
Much of the collagen forms these fibers,
who are involved in the construction
of the extracellular matrix.
Look at these cells here,
the things I've painted around them
make them look as if they are embedded in the extracellular matrix.
They may be fixed.
They look like hanging
for the matrix, it helps them occupy a certain position.
This is true of the extracellular matrix,
collagen fibers and other elements constituting the extracellular matrix,
attach the cells and help them get organized so that they build fabrics.
The extracellular matrix, as well as other factors,
can tell the cell when to grow, when to divide
and even when to die or when to produce
different types of molecules.
To understand better
what is actually happening,
how the cage is attached,
we have to take a closer look here,
for example in this box.
We will look closely at the cell membrane,
we can switch to this diagram,
it occupies most of the screen.
This diagram shows an enlarged view of the enclosed box.
On this side we have the inside of the cage.
This is the inside of the cell,
we see that there is
actin microfilament,
which forms part of the cytoskeleton.
We also have collagen fibers,
which form part of the extracellular matrix.
We see that these two parts are connected, hooked to each other through
these proteins.
These proteins are called integrins.
Integrins.
They are located in the membrane
of the cage and other fibers,
such as fibronectin,
can be linked to
extracellular matrix.
This is really interesting because, in this way,
structurally binding the extracellular
matrix
and the interior of the cell,
and the cytoskeleton. The connection is thanks to these proteins.
They help
these things connect, lock them in place.
In addition, they can also be used for signaling,
they can count their voltage
depending on the type of cell,
can signal the cell
to activate or deactivate.
It's really remarkable.
I want to make it clear,
that very often when you study biology
even at the most basic level,
you will see the things written in textbooks
and you may think, "Oh, of course, we have integrals,
which pass through the plasma membrane
and are attached to fibronectin
and for the cytoskeleton,
of course they are related to collagen,
through the extracellular matrix. "
It sounds like the whole biology is open,
learned and clear.
But the answers to questions like
how exactly all these proteins work together, how they signal,
how cells understand what to do
based on how much tension
has on them or how much "populated" with other cells a given area.
These answers are still being sought through active research.
In fact, if you get a little older
in everything I speak of,
I recommend you do it,
you will find new scientific articles,
in which people ask, "How this one
integrin knows exactly what to do? "
or "How exactly does it send an alert to the cell?",
or "How to connect
with the cytoskeleton or extracellular matrix? "
These are interesting scientific questions
and people are dealing with them
for a long time, as there are always new questions
about how these extremely complex proteins
and glycoproteins - Fibronectin is a glycoprotein,
the side chains of its protein moiety
have
carbohydrate chains, sugar chains,
who are branching out of them.
How all these things interact
and how they know what to do,
how do all these complicated signaling mechanisms work?
This is a very interesting area of ​​research.
I hope this video showed you
and helped you appreciate,
the complexity of the structures they build, and they make the one that you are.
We have already talked about the fact that cells themselves are complex,
but they are found in the extracellular matrix,
which helps defining tissues,
it also helps the cells
to live in "society"
and to know how to relate and relate to each other. Also the extracellular matrix
has a role in signaling from the external environment to the cell.
Here I drew one
integrin complex,
but there are many of them
along the membrane
and they are not the only proteins.
This is a remarkable detail for the cell membrane,
which you will often see, painted only as a dual phospholipid layer.
Actually, the membrane is located
any proteins,
which can be used as receptors allowing different molecules
to enter or exit the cage.
We see the cells
are like big cities that
can communicate with their more remote environment.